You are listening to
radiolab radio from w n y s
oh look, it's so it's hard to kill
another human being anymore, right?
We, our fangs have
retreated, hands are weak.
But as we've lost this
ability to kill each other,
we've gained an ability to read each
other's tone of voice and facial
expression.
And often what's missing in these
interactions is one side of that equation.
Uh,
whether it's the police
not seeing somebody because
they're running through an
alley with their gun drawn and,
and it's dark or shining a flashlight in
someone's face where that person can't
see the officer's expression.
There's some mass cause
there's some breakdown in that,
in that equation that makes
handicaps us from a
normal human interaction.
Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad by him,
Robert Krulwich, this is Radiolab.
And today we are once again taking a deep
dive into Tampa Bay Times reporter Ben
Montgomery's mountain of data
about police shootings in Florida.
So to refresh your memory from,
so we've tried to account for every
single police shooting from January 1st of
2009 to um, December 31st of 2014.
And we've just to remind you,
Ben and [inaudible], his team
at the Tampa Bay Times collected
data from 828 police shootings.
And there's all kinds of stories
that you can tell about this data.
Last week we looked at police training
and race and racism and obviously there's
so much more than can and should
be said about all of that.
But this week we're going to go in a
very different direction. Maybe Matt,
you just want to set this up for us. Yes.
So we want to tell this story because
it actually plays out this, uh,
this idea that Ben just mentioned that
there's this sort of communication
breakdown that happens and it does it in
a very particular way because when one
of these cases comes before a court,
the court more often than not will only
look at the moment that the cop involved
in the shooting pulled their trigger.
You don't consider any other moment.
It's only the objective facts
on the ground of the moment,
the officer applies force.
So the thing that we found compelling
about this story is that in this case you
can actually see, and kind of
a rare instance you can like,
as you can step in and see all the little
moments that lead up to that moment
and you realize how complicated
these interactions get.
So this particular story, it's
a story about white couple, uh,
Andrea and Rick Sheldon and we're actually
going to start the story with Rick.
So on one of my trips, uh, to Florida,
Ben and I drove to the northeast corner
of the state of near Jacksonville to
Rick's place. It's sorta like
the, the wilds of Florida.
Hi. How you doing Matt? Kielty
nice to meet you. Nice to meet you.
Like sort of thoughts that great wild.
Oh, that's a big bird back there.
What all, what all do
you have on the property?
Pretty much a little bit of everything.
He clicks rain water and barrels.
He's got potatoes, tomatoes, squash,
these organic cartons, ducks,
goats, a lot of animals. Turkeys,
big turkeys. Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh. Oh,
a couple of dogs in the
house. Oh, you are so excited.
I'm gonna hit stop in
this case, the battery
[inaudible] uh, eventually we all
sit down and Rick's living room.
Rick sat cross-legged on the couch. Um,
Rick, I was just wondering if we could,
uh, I pulled up a chair across from
him if we could talk about your case,
but even backing up before everything
happened, um, can you just tell me about,
about your, about your
wife? I met Andy. Um,
she was down here
visiting her mom and, uh,
we hit it off straight from the get
go. Where'd you, where'd you guys meet?
Tradewinds lounge. Downtown. St
Augustine. At a bar downtown? Yup. Yup.
What'd she look like? Oh, knock
out 10 dark dark hair. How tall?
Oh, short little thing. If I flipped
to you, make the first move a no,
we kind of made the same move the same
time. And I can remember telling her,
you know, we have a live burn tomorrow.
Rick was in China to be a firefighter at
the academy and one of our last events
and uh, that I'd call her whenever
I got done and we'd go have dinner.
She's like, no, you're not going to call
me. You just gonna come over. I'm like,
I'm going to be stinky. She's like, nope.
Cause I know that if you
go back to your place,
you're gonna pass out tired
and I'll never see you again,
so you're just going to come over here
and take a shower. And I showed up,
I ate dinner. So that was a date
number one? Yep. Pretty much.
So Rick says they just, you
know, sort of connected.
And so the data for about a year,
she moved down here and then, um,
two of them got married and
she went to nursing school.
Later became a hospice nurse. Rick, uh,
eventually became a firefighter for
Jackson fire rescue. If we were to, uh,
to jump ahead to the night in question,
could you just like back up to like the
beginning of the day and just kind of
walk me through? Yeah, we woke up
extra early. What Day is this? Um,
April the 15th. 2012 yeah.
Okay, so you woke up? Yeah.
Um, we were in at our cabin
and Georgia getting it ready,
getting it all set up and whatnot and uh,
it was going to be a retirement
place anyway, packed up, came home,
long drive, long hot drive
when we got home, you know,
started unpacking the car a little bit
and started doing a little bit of this,
that and the other,
doing a little bit chatting and talking
about dinner and having a couple of
drinks, whatnot. What
happened after that? Now?
I don't know.
We just kinda started getting grumpy
at each other and getting grumpy.
Now we talked about this for a while.
I'm just wondering if you can
remember just kind of any detail of,
of what you guys were talking about.
Um, and Rick didn't want to get into it.
I'd rather not make a
statement about that right now.
Just about the conversations
you guys were having.
I'd rather not make a statement
about that right now. Okay. Oh,
you can say according to the police
report is that Rick and Andy got into this
screaming match and Rick says that
he felt himself shortness of breath,
chest pain, starting to kind of unravel,
lost a concentration and ability to think.
Rick says he's had problems
with PTSD for quite a while.
It goes back to his former
job as a paramedic. And I'm
like, I can't take this.
I need to walk away.
Grabbed a bottle out of the refrigerator
and I got in my truck and I went and I
was like, okay, I'm just
going to go fishing.
Drove down this dirt road
for about five miles.
I went to the big pond down there, but
right over by the pond I was stuck.
His truck gets stuck in
the mud. I was axle deep.
So you opened up this bottle of
Tequila and he starts drinking.
He keeps drinking. Eventually
pop some pills, sleeping pills.
Next thing I remember was, um, you
know, um, I remember having problems.
I remember being upset. I
remember having my, you know,
it's PTSD. It sucks. I remember,
um, calling my boss going,
hey, I need some help.
And, um, ask for help. Ask for, um,
employee assistance program help,
you know the suicide hotline. Oh,
you thought you were suicidal
in that moment? Um, no.
I just thought I was losing it.
And in what way is it just like,
I'm just trying to put you off
digging. Yeah, stop digging.
You don't want to look in his
head. It gets that bad. Yeah.
Um, did he say anything to you? I
don't remember the conversation. Okay.
What happened after that? Um,
next thing I know I've got
the cops calling me going. Where are you?
Hello Richard.
This is recording that phone call.
Deputy Halston was sheriff's office.
I Bet I done. Hey, we're, uh,
we're trying to come out
here and help you. Um,
it's about 11,
15 at night and deputy tells Rick that
he and a few other deputies are walking
down this dirt road to Rick's place
because they'd gotten a call that Rick was
possibly suicidal, that he'd
gotten into a fight with his wife.
Um, where are you at?
I have no idea though.
It tells the deputy that he got
in his truck, drove a ways away
until I got stopped and I opened
it and I've been enjoying myself.
Your wife had the house?
Yeah, it's still okay.
Everything all right there at the
house. Everything's okay at the house.
Okay. We're mass to dispute. Can you
ws well can I get her phone number?
Cause he'd like to make contact with her.
We want to make sure everybody's safe
cause you know we got deputies out here.
It's dark, you know,
and we don't want her to think that
we're somebody proud and stuff.
So when we want her to know
it was worse, so hoppy,
I was the best way we can make
contact while her eight, two, three,
Rick gives the deputy
his home phone number.
You write this down. All
right. Okay. So we're gonna,
we're going to try to make contact
with heart and then um, um,
I must be on the phone with you.
We're going to try to get another deputy
to call her so that we can get her to
come outside. Okay.
To have them talk for
about another minute.
You're not playing all harm yourself
or anything, are you? Nah Man.
Huh? Nah, just [inaudible]
was last night and you just want to leave.
So at this point, the deputy standing
at the edge of Rick and Amy's driveway,
Rick is still a few miles
away over at his truck.
When suddenly in the background
of the call, you just hear
[inaudible]
fired. Who?
That was firing shots.
That's Rick trying to
figure out what happened.
Debbie.
Huh?
Heavy d p d.
Well, what, what happened
there? Okay, so, um,
what we know is while the
deputy was talking to Rick,
the other officers that
were with the deputy, uh,
had gone ahead and gone up
to the house. Rick's wife,
Andy heard something came out
of the House with a shotgun.
The deputies say that she pointed
the shotgun at one of the deputies.
They opened fire and she was shot
and killed there on the front porch.
Did they say,
did they identify themselves or like how
did the police surprise her? OK. Okay.
So actually, uh,
so Ben and I were able to get all of
the police dispatch recordings from that
night. And if you go
through these recordings,
what you hear is this crazily drawn out
version of what Ben was talking about at
the top of the story,
the disconnect that happens between the
deputies and the dispatchers and what
they're thinking, hearing and seeing
and what's actually happening.
Okay, so if you rewind to about
40 minutes before that shooting,
the first thing that happened
was Rick called his boss.
Now we don't know exactly what was said
in that phone call because it wasn't
recorded.
But what we do know is that Rick's boss
left that conversation believing that
Rick might be possibly suicidal, that
there've been a fight at the house,
that Rick a had some guns with him in
his truck cause Rick and Andy had gone
camping and that there was gun
back at the house. But anyways,
the first thing that happened after that
call,
it's Rick's bosses, he's a fire
chief, calls fire dispatch,
who calls a sheriff dispatcher
who ropes in another,
the St John's county
sheriff's office can help you,
sheriff dispatcher. And what happens is
all three dispatchers get on the line
and who is what? Who is that? The woods
trying to figure out what's going on.
His wife is no dad.
Eventually the sheriff dispatcher,
this is a special number three.
He's just like,
okay, let me just call the
Stephen Jenkinson information.
I'll call the fire chief
back. Try and figure this out.
I'll tell you this job site right now,
right around the time that dispatch
number three is making that call somehow
another sheriff's dispatch or a fourth
dispatch here to Charlie Walker Shack
decides to put out a call for a welfare
check and basically ask a couple of
devotees to go to Rick's house
and make sure everything's okay.
Okay. It's advised that he is in
the woods and it has a handgun,
which is true. Rick says he had
one in the back of the truck,
but he says it wasn't loaded,
but then things start to get more
complicated because when dispatcher number
three gets a hold of Rick's
boss, the fire chief.
That's Greg. Can you just start with
giving me some details? He called him.
What's his issue? What's the deal? It's,
it says when Rick called him, I said,
Gee, if I'm out here on into woods,
my wife gave to me with a gun.
He just couldn't take it anymore.
And then he hung up on no,
Rick denies having said anything
like that to his boss and his boss.
As you'll hear, it does seem to walk some
of the back, but all right, thank you.
Yep.
Things are kind of already set in motion
cause then supposedly dispatch number
four relays the chief story
to the deputies in route.
Wife has a signal zero handgun is chasing
the male who took medication on the
right. He's hallucinating
or what's going on,
but then that same dispatcher does
special four calls. Rick's boss,
the fire chief.
Okay. Now his wife is chasing him
and he's like, well Chasey Yep.
Information that he told
me to his wife had a gun,
which Rick says he said, but just that
there was a gun in the house. That's it.
Uh Huh. And hottie plumber
in the woods. Okay.
Is she starting to kill him? You
didn't say anything like that.
Clarification.
Male half is hiding from his wife who
signaled zero with the handgun in fear of
her or trying to get more.
10 43 48 four. Thank you.
And this is what Ben is talking about,
about these sort of clouds
of miscommunication because
by the time the police
show up at this house for what
is normally a welfare check,
south Radio Williams, now she has a
shotgun inside the house. She has pills.
I'm like, Hey, what'd you got? She's
chased them off into the woods.
What's that address?
He's also armed, maybe even
hallucinating. So the deputies, they uh,
damn dork out here were
blocked out walking. Yeah,
I'll pull up in a blackout.
Just be careful. Um,
the nature of the police lights,
they get out of the cars,
they don't even turn on their flashlights
and they start walking down this road
to Rick's place.
And one of the deputies even puts on
these night vision goggles because they
think this woman has chased
her husband and the woods.
Supposedly he's in the
woods by his house. So just
send out too.
And is the deputy stopped walking down
this dirt road towards spritz place.
Pepper first situation gets more intense.
What just happened? What did you do?
Get it out. Dolls Gum.
Cause like the neighbor's dog is starting
to freak out, but eventually, okay,
we're here. We're B six deputies
get to the edge of Rick's Treadway
go. I'll call you back. Okay,
thank you. Bye. Be careful.
It's actually right around here.
About 40 minutes after Rick made
that first call to his boss,
the Rick gets a call from the deputy.
Oh, it's your fault. I bet. Higher down.
So you know the two of
them talk for a while.
Deputy's trying to figure out where
Rick is and eventually you ask.
So say your wife's daughter,
your wife's got a gun? No,
I took all the guns with me
except for she's got 12 gauge.
Okay. Okay. Everything all
right up there at the house
and Rick slate. Yeah.
Does bringing folks at the house, we're
fine. Just okay. We're last to dispute.
No reason to be worried.
But as the deputy is talking to Rick,
um, I must be on the phone
for the deputies start
walking up Rick's driveway.
They want to check on Andy
so they get up to the house.
Two of them walk up onto
the porch. One of them,
he looks through the bedroom window
where Andy is and she has no reason to
believe the police are
anywhere on her property.
She was asleep and
presumably she heard a noise,
grabbed the shotgun in the house and
came outside. Now in this moment,
all we really have to go on is
what the cops said they saw,
which is Andy came out through the front
door wearing nothing but her underwear
holding the shotgun. The cop
save. They identified themselves.
They were screaming at
her to drop the gun.
They say that Andy took a step forward,
leveled the shotgun against her
shoulder, and then they opened fire.
If I have 24 shots, they hit Andy at
least eight times. She fell to the porch.
Uh, some of the police officers rushed
to her, began performing first aid.
Eventually they radio for an ambulance
and paramedics showed up and pronounced
Andy dead at the scene.
Hmm.
Did at this point, do you
have any idea what happened,
honey? No, not a clue.
I realized that I needed
to snap out, wake up,
get my ass in gear and find out
what's going on. But Rick's truck
was stuck and so it took a few hours,
but eventually the cops figured out where
he was sent a crew over to meet him.
Yeah. The ground crew came over
and picked me up, handcuffed me,
and put me in the back of a pickup
truck and took me to headquarters.
They got them out of the car. I brought
him into headquarters, put me in a room,
typical interrogation type room. And then
I started noticing that they were, um,
being very, very friendly. Some people
saying something about, you know, my,
my camping equipment in the
truck. I remember them, um, uh,
authorizing me to have a
cigarette and the broom.
And then we pretty much went through
the same questioning that we've gone
through so far. And, uh, at which
time they um, informed me that um,
they had come out to the
house to check on Andy and um,
she had come to the door and there was
an altercation and they shot and killed
her. That was the phrasing.
It is pretty much, yeah.
And altercation. Yes. When you
hear something like that, I mean,
I can't even fathom how you
respond to some news like that.
I still can't fathom responding to it.
Did you say anything to
them? Am I under arrest?
Get these fucking cuffs off me.
How long did it take them to,
to uncuff you? I don't remember.
Were you saying anything to him while you
were still cuffed from that moment on?
I pretty much,
well, I mean,
what do you say when somebody looks
at you and says your wife is dead?
We shot and killed her.
Yeah. The, the absolute
implosion of your mind. Just
the searing pain. They
explosive feeling the need.
Do I get angry? Do I get
sad? Do I break down and cry?
Do I fall apart?
Do I hold it together long enough to
where I can figure out what the hell just
happened. You know what
you did what?
You went out to my house in the
middle of night and you shot my wife.
I mean, how do you
respond to that? I mean,
to this day I'm still six, seven,
20, 50 times a day asking myself,
what are you talking about?
You mean she can't be dead?
What are you talking about?
No, no.
Did you see her at all
after the shooting? Yes.
It's about two weeks afterwards.
Where was that at? The funeral home.
Um, went over to the funeral home and I'm
sorry, my feet are going
to sleep. Yeah, no. Um,
and reached down and kiss her and um,
felt the edge of what I
thought was a casket move
and it was that time that realized
that she was on a cardboard box
that just had frill on it to make it
look pretty. Did you say anything to her?
Oh yeah. Yeah.
Told her that we really need to do
something about her hair because it was a
mess.
And the rest of what I said
to her is between me and her.
I you break. Yeah, no, of
course. Um, take a break.
I put the microphone down. Rick
got up and went over the kitchen,
import himself a pretty
big glass of vodka. Um,
we of just walked around
the property for a while. We kept talking.
Eventually Rick pulled out this computer
bag that he keeps buried in his closet.
Yeah. Grandma. Of all
the shooters involved,
it's this bag full of and the shots fired.
[inaudible] all the police reports
that were made about that night. Uh,
medical examiner's autopsy report. Yeah.
You Know How many times I've sat down and
just written through all the questions
I have. Yeah.
The autopsy report that said that there
was no sir previous surgeries really,
she just had her gallbladder
taken out. Is it,
these are just questions that
constantly kept going on. You know,
coward says the, he made
eye contact with her.
That's deputy Thomas Calgary
and she with him. Okay.
So a guy is standing at the window.
You've seen the elevation of the window
compared to wearing wherever a six foot
tall person that's standing at it.
You're really telling me
that you made eye contact.
Rick also has all the recordings
of the police dispatch.
How many times have you listened to
those recordings? Countless. Nonstop.
Is that like a daily thing? Hourly. He
says he just can't stop asking himself.
How did this happen? And then
eventually a, who's got the map?
Rick walked us outside, uh, diagrams
back and said, Rick went back inside,
came back out with this map
that his lawyers had tron up.
Take this map and position yourself in
the positions where the shooters were at.
He started having me and Ben, uh,
walk through the shooting of his wife,
kind of like going and placing
herself where each officer was.
This one down here,
he's the one that testified that he
couldn't see what he was shooting at.
He just knew that the other
guys were shooting. See,
he's on the other side of the,
and the other side of that tank.
He watches over close to the
portrait. One of the officers was,
and you can see some of the bullet
holes in the house. Yeah, here.
There I say that's it.
So bullet went through. You're
tore up, tore up the uh,
plastic. Then we were off the front
porch over in the front yard with three.
The deputies were,
so they see her come out and they
started moving across like this.
Yeah.
Shooting a almost naked woman on our
front porch in the middle of the night in
the middle of the swamp.
Fuck them.
Rick then walked inside and
left us standing in his yard.
No,
about four months after Andrew
Sheldon was shot and killed,
the state attorney's office sent a
letter to the Florida Department of law
enforcement that it conducted
investigation in the
shooting saying that there'd
be no charges brought against the
officers stating that what they did was a
quote, justifiable use of deadly force.
Rick has filed a civil complaint on
behalf of the estate of Andrea Sheldon.
The complaint alleges each officer
involved in the shooting violated civil
rights, used excessive force,
didn't follow training policy and
procedure and intentionally inflicted
emotional distress on Rick.
When we reached out to the Saint
John's county sheriff's office,
they said they could not comment
on the case pending litigation.
[inaudible]
big thanks to our producer,
Matt Kielty and uh,
Tampa Bay Times reporter Ben
Montgomery. Definitely, uh,
keep an eye on our website,
radiolab.org as soon as the Tampa
Bay Times big feature is up,
we will link you there and it's
definitely worth checking out.
radiolab.org it's the address I'm
Jad Abumrad I'm Robert Krulwich.
Thanks for listening.